Let's plug in a β of 0, so when not moving, the two frames we're discussing aren't moving at all,
the train is at rest, well we've have 1/√1-0, which is 1/1.
It turns out that that's the lowest possible value that gamma can ever take, so that's gamma min.
For gamma max, as we get closer and closer to 1, as β gets closer and closer to 1,
well 1 minus that number squared does get smaller and smaller,
and as we divide by a smaller and smaller number, we get bigger and bigger,
and it turns out that the maximum value is as high as we would like.
And so actually if we want to plot this value gamma versus β, well we defined that for a very long time
gamma is very close to 1, but then it quickly rises and gets bigger and bigger and bigger
as β approaches 1 or as we approach the speed of light.
What is that mean? It means that this number gets bigger.
It means that the time measured on the stationary observer's clock
gets longer and longer when compared to the moving observer.
This is why we call it time dilation. Let's look at an example to see if we can make some sense in this.